tenemos aquí la expresión 2 x + 4 x 5 x
9 igual a a x al cuadrado más x menos 36
y lo que queremos hacer aquí es
encontrar cuáles son los valores de a y
bb entonces te recomiendo que le pongas
una pausa del vídeo y lo intentes por tu
cuenta
bueno pues hay varias formas de resolver
este ejercicio y una de ellas sería
tomar estos dos binomios y
multiplicarlos y ver si del producto que
nos queda podemos asociar algunos
términos con esto que tenemos por aquí y
entonces asociar los coeficientes así es
que vamos a multiplicar estos dos de
aquí que hay varias formas de hacer esto
pero a mí me gusta pensar que estoy
utilizando la propiedad distributiva dos
veces así es que toda esta expresión de
la izquierda la podemos reescribir de
esta forma lo que tomamos todo este
binomio 2x + 4 y lo vamos a distribuir
en el 5x menos 9 así es que nos queda 2
x + 4 x 5 x más 2 x + 4 x menos 95 x x 2
x más 4 y luego esto lo podemos ver como
un + menos 9 x 2 x 24 o simplemente como
un -9 x 2 x + 4
2x + 4 y lo único que hemos hecho hasta
ahorita es distribuir el 2 x 4 en el 5x
menos 9 pero ahora que tenemos esto por
aquí de 5 x por 2 x + 4
podemos ahora distribuir el 5 x podemos
distribuir el 5 x en el 2x + 4 y cuánto
es 5x por 2x pues es 10 x al cuadrado y
5 x por 4 es 20 x y menos 9 por 2x es
menos 18 x y menos 9 por 4 es menos 36 y
ahora podemos simplificar esto porque
tenemos aquí dos términos de primer
grado así es que tenemos aquí 10 x x al
cuadrado y luego tenemos estos dos
términos de primer grado y si tengo 20 x
y le quitó 18 de esas x pues me van a
quedar únicamente 2 x 20 menos 18 es 2 y
por supuesto voy a seguir teniendo aquí
un -36 ahora lo único que he hecho hasta
ahorita es simplificar o reescribir de
otra forma el lado izquierdo de esta
ecuación no hay que recordar que esto es
una ecuación y entonces esto de aquí
tiene que ser igual a esto que teníamos
por acá
así es que esto tiene que ser igual a x
x al cuadrado más b x menos 36 claro que
ahorita que lo puse de estos colores
seguramente ya estás pensando en cuáles
valores tienen que tomar a y b tenemos
por aquí 10 x al cuadrado y el término
de segundo grado de este lado por aquí
es a por x al cuadrado entonces
tiene que ser igual a que estos dos
coeficientes tienen que ser iguales así
es que podemos escribir que a es igual a
10 y después cuando nos fijamos en el
término de primer grado
aquí tenemos 2x y por acá tenemos b x
entonces 2 tiene que ser igual a b o sea
que b tiene que ser igual a 2 y bueno
está muy bien que nuestras constantes
sean iguales así es que ya tenemos esto
por aquí a es igual a 10 y b es igual a
2 ahora ya que tienes mucha práctica con
todo esto tal vez quieras encontrar una
forma de encontrar a ive más rápido
aunque tal vez en esa otra forma puede
ser más fácil equivocarse pero bueno
para encontrar más rápidamente a a1
puede ponerse a pensar de qué forma
puedo obtener x al cuadrado en esta
multiplicación de binomios por acá lo
que hay cuando multiplico estas cosas de
aquí
obtengo un x al cuadrado y la única
forma de obtener x al cuadrado es si
multiplico este 2x por el 5x y lo que me
queda es 10 x al cuadrado y entonces
podemos decir que a es igual a 10 y
después podemos preguntarnos por cómo
podemos obtener una equis y pues hay dos
formas de obtener x una de ellas es
tomar dos equis y multiplicarlo por
menos nueve y eso nos da menos 18 x o
también podemos multiplicar 4 por 5 x
que nos da 20 x y si sumamos estos dos
de aquí nos va a dar 2x así es que aquí
tenemos 12 tenemos de x y tenemos 2 x
por lo que ve
tiene que ser igual a 2 y después
podemos secar ahora como voy a obtener
un -36 vamos a tener que multiplicar 4 x
menos 9 pero 4 x menos 9 si es 36 ahora
esta segunda forma de encontrar a ive
puede ser más rápida también puede ser
que uno cometa más errores con esta
forma pero en realidad estoy haciendo
exactamente lo mismo que hicimos por
aquí la única diferencia es el nivel de
claridad